notre invité gilbert casasus professeur
d'études européennes
gilbert casasus bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
ça y est le royaume uni entre dans une
nouvelle ère dans un contexte de crise
économique puisque à 23h gmt il ne
faudra plus partie de l'union européenne
il devra donc avec ses propres règles
concrètement quels changements sont
attendus dès demain alors d'abord le
départ du la grande-bretagne européenne
du trot 15 janvier dernier mais c'est
vrai que dans les fêtes c'est à vous
aujourd'hui à vendanger mtq on pourra
dire que la grand-bretagne
définitivement dit au revoir
voir adieu à l'union européenne ce qui
va changer c'est très simplement la
folle finances et de la grande bretagne
n'est plus un pays qui va bénéficier des
avantages mais aussi dit certain
inconvénient il faut le leur dire de
l'union européenne c'est à dire que
c'est un pays qui va se trouver hors du
champ communautaire et qu'un certain
nombre de règles notamment financières
économiques commerciales et également
régaliennes ne vont plus appliquée pour
la grande bretagne
c'est à dire cite le cas d'un divorce
plus ou moins l'amiable qui n'arrange à
un vrai dire pas grand monde et qui
pourra créer quelques nouveaux problèmes
ou que nous ne connaissons pas encore
dans leur ampleur alors on a beaucoup
parlé un du côté économique des
relations
voilà qui les relations futures entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
mais concrètement pour les citoyens qui
sont habitués à circuler sans obstacle
depuis plus de quarante sept ans entre
le et le royaume-uni quelles seront les
règles dès demain alors il y à un
paradoxe extraordinaire vous savez que
la grande bretagne se dit être le bmi
libéralisme est bien le libéralisme de
boris johnson s'est plus de bureaucratie
c'est à dire qu'il y aura plus de bureau
crasse que ce soit pour des marchandises
que ce soit aussi pour le commun des
mortels
car même s'il n'y aura pas de frontières
de l'ue
bien en paix fera de d'avoir beaucoup
plus de contrôle à la frontière
il faudra à part quelques mois de
septembre pour les revendre en bretagne
non le cas d'une entité mais un
passeport et puis peut-être parce que je
suis professeur d'université mais c'est
grave c'est la femme du programme
erasmus pour les étudiants britanniques
qui ne pourront plus venir étudier par
exemple français en france ils le feront
certainement dans les midlands ce sera
nettement meilleure qualité pour une
exploration mais surtout aussi beaucoup
d'étudiants européens dans les débuts en
français ne pourront plus se rendre en
bretagne tout va payer des taxes énormes
et l'a véritablement au niveau de
l'ordre de l'intelligence et à grand pas
en arrière
vous l'avez dit un cet accord va
chambouler les échances dans les études
supérieures
vous vous attendez à des conséquences
assez terrible pour les étudiants des
deux côtés je connaissais un peu par la
fiche parce qu'en suisse il ya eu ce
problème en 2014 et la suisse a mis un
programme de remplacement qui fonctionne
plus ou moins mais c'est tout clairement
à comme j'ai dis un grand pas en arrière
c'est à dire que les étudiants français
ne pouvons pas se payer plus de 10000
euros de frais de scolarité par an et
que des étudiants britanniques ne
pourront plus bénéficier aussi de une
présence dans les andes universitaires
européennes il faut savoir que la même
si on n'est pas dans le monde des
clients et ce même si reconnaissable de
loin
c'est tout simplement la production
ligue et c'est la recherche c'est les
échanges qui sont véritablement taxés
dans tous les sens du terme par ses
politiques
les effets sont en effet que le
prends pas moment on prendra
connaissance à court terme qui se font
ressentir ressortir à plus ou moins long
terme
et là nous avons véritablement un
problème qui va se poser entre la grande
bretagne et lorraine et l'union
européenne
c'est pourquoi je considère qu' il
serait excellent aujourd'hui que
l'étudiant université de l'espace
communautaire définissent des politiques
de coopération dans les champs un peu
les l'université britannique sur la
touche il n'y a pas qu'au oxford et
cambridge grande-bretagne a aussi
d'autres d'université et c'est surtout
celle ci beaucoup moins connu est
beaucoup moins bonnes qui vont payer les
frais de la politique du broustic alors
le sort de gibraltar l'enclavé espagnole
est toujours en suspens c'est que le
gouvernement espagnol a lancé un
ultimatum à londres justement pour
résoudre ce problème
que prévoit l'accord pour cette enclave
britannique situé à l'extrême pointe de
l'andalousie
vous ne fait pas un spécial de libre
alter donc je veux pas répondre en
détail mais ce qui se passe c'est le
problème que gibraltar ne peut vivre que
par la présence de nombreux espagnols
qui travaillent et aussi c'est un lieu
de passage entre l'europe et l'afrique
donc là aussi
s'il n'y a pas d'accord claire et nette
eux les la multiplication des problèmes
administratifs à se poser et de surcroît
à un grave problème de voyage de
transition de passage entre l'afrique et
l'europe
donc il faut savoir que les relations
entre la grande-bretagne et l'espagne
sont toujours très délicate à cause de
gibraltar et que si relation puisque
véritablement encore plus de se
détériorer dans un avenir proche
la dernière question très très
rapidement il ya un secteur aussi qui
inquiète enfin sur ce break site c'est
le secteur de la culture
on sait que
voilà ce secteur a d'ailleurs lancé une
pétition en ligne pour demander au
gouvernement britannique de revoir le
statut des travailleurs de cette
industrie culturelle pourquoi selon vous
les musiciens artistes britanniques
pensent que ce break ci pourrait
asphyxier s'estimant les échanges
culturels entre le royaume uni et
l'europe
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont raison
ils savent très bien que la culture vie
de les champs vie une ouverture d'esprit
et quand on ferme et échange les cantons
se referme outils au niveau de l'esprit
bas tout simplement en lutte en paient
le prix financier mais aussi le prix
intellectuelle et si vous voulez c'est
très intéressant de voir que les
artistes britanniques se mobilisent
parce qu'ils savent très bien que la
culture notamment musicales mais pas
seulement britannique héron réputé et
apprécié dans le reste de l'europe et
que là il risque aussi de devenir une
victime de cette de ce combat gay
logiquement mené par boris johnson et
compagnie il faut être clair et net
le bric site est un recul le break site
est une mauvaise nouvelle pour l'europe
mais aussi pour la bretagne et surtout
pour les britanniques
et si vous voulez quand on recule bien
tout simplement on remarque on en paye à
un moment donné le prix je ne sais pas
quand la facture sera proposé aux
européens et notamment britanniques
mais le risque d'être assez salée est
beaucoup plus salée qu'on veuille bien
le dire actuellement
merci beaucoup gilbert casasus d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'études
européennes à free voir